dark personalities are more likely to  signal victimhood so that surprises me a  bit because i always thought that it was  more agreeable people that tended  towards being victims but that's not  what this suggests it's a little bit  tricky so the researchers were not  claiming based on the studies that they  ran that actual victims score higher on  dark triad personality traits what they  were claiming is that people who tend to  score high on dark triad personality  traits tend to signal victimhood more  and signaling victimhood is not  necessarily the same thing as actually  being a victim right and so people who  are truly the targets of misfortune or  suffering have really gone through bad  things those aren't the people who you  know tend to be narcissists or  psychopaths but the people tend to be  narcissists and psychopaths will sort of  exploit people's empathy by playing a  victim